de nuevo la guardia nacional protegiendo
el capitolio de eeuu apenas tres meses
después del asalto al capitolio por
parte de seguidores exaltados de donald
trump un asaltante mató a un policía e
hirió a otro frente al congreso el
oficial que murió fue identificado como
william evans un veterano con 18 años de
trabajo en la policía del capitolio
dos agentes de la policía del capitolio
de eeuu fueron trasladados a dos
hospitales diferentes y con el corazón
encogido anunció que uno de los agentes
ha sucumbido a sus heridas el sospechoso
identificado como no a green de 25 años
y proveniente del estado de indiana fue
disparado por los agentes al salir de su
vehículo con un cuchillo en la mano
justo antes lo había embestido contra
una de las barreras de seguridad que
protege al capitolio art pops muy ones
dio aproximadamente a la una de esta
tarde un sospechoso entró en lo que
llamamos la barricada norte del
capitolio el sospechoso en vistió con su
cuchara dos de nuestros agentes y luego
chocó contra
barricada norte en este momento salió
del vehículo con un cuchillo a la mano
por el momento la policía no ha
esclarecido las razones por las que
green podría haber cometido el ataque si
bien descartan por lo pronto el móvil
terrorista no parece estar relacionado
con el terrorismo pero obviamente
seguiremos investigando para ver si hay
algún tipo de nexo en esa línea los
congresistas se encuentran actualmente
de vacaciones por semana santa por lo
que el edificio se encontraba
prácticamente vacío el presidente badén
quien lamentó el suceso al decir que
tiene el corazón roto tampoco se
encontraba en washington pues había
salido temprano para su residencia de
camp davis terminada la jornada a los
compañeros de evans lo homenajearon con
una procesión de vehículos policiales
que acompañó su féretro hasta el
instituto forense